take a look at this beautiful view wow  it's  definitely a sign that the seasons has  changed  mark charleston saw its first snowfall  of the season  and this is some fresh video from our  aviator drone  gorgeous view very popular here in the  studio i'm sure popular with you at home  too and ted  any idea of how much snow they got is it  still up there is it gone  no it's still up there i mean when it's  cold down here that stuff is going to  stay there all right i think it's going  to stay there all week there too so  yeah recapping everything we had that's  a great shot there from our aviator  drone  that we got from uh matt adams earlier  uh this weekend  the mountain snow lee kenya picked up  four inches of snow we knew that was  going to happen mount charleston eight  inches of snow up there